whenever people fail to achieve their
goals 99.9% of time you ask him why
they'll tell you it's because of a lack
of resources that's what all these
things are I didn't have the support
right I didn't have the money we didn't
have the time we didn't have this we
know that there's a resource that people
believe is missing and that resource
belief structure then keeps people from
ever being able to really lead because
what leaders do is they find a way to
maximize whatever resources they have
has littlez they maybe and they don't
believe in limited resources resources
are interesting but the ultimate
resources are the feelings of emotion
that make you resourceful think of it
this way resourcefulness is the ultimate
resource how many got an idea for
example was a great idea you're excited
about it and then you didn't do anything
one day there you saw it on the shelf
you saw it somewhere so let's stole your
idea how many had this happen say ah
you'll understand you and that person
was not that they have more resources
they were more resourceful success and
failure are not giant events they don't
just show up you don't just suddenly
become successful or suddenly have this
cataclysmic event that makes you fail
and they look that way but failure comes
from all the little things its failure
to make the call its failure to check
the books its failure to say I'm sorry
its failure to push yourself to do
things physically that you don't want to
do and all those little failures day
after day come together until one day
some Cataclysm event happens you blame
Matt that event happened because you
missed all the little stuff and success
by the way is not some overnight event
it's all these little things success is
having a vision and success is making a
compelling success is really seeing and
feeling and everyday was strong enough
for reasons success he is feeling the
sense that I'm here to grow and I'm here
to give something to the world more than
just myself all the little stuff that's
where success comes from in business it
comes from delivering more than anybody
could imagine all those little things
add up people go wow that's who I want
to do business with you just watched two
amazing clips from Tony Robbins take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]